[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à paris il ya des actions qui
se passe on y voit de la ville au niveau
des entreprises
un simple
ratp l'autre jour il avait laissé les
tickets antipollution quelque chose
comme ça qu'ils a coûté un euro 80 toute
la journée et ils en pensent quoi votre
frère mon frère non seulement ne veux
faire mon rabat pas demain la familia la
famille guyana et amérique du sud 1 on a
fait corps ni à des landes mexique au
brésil padam un souci mais on doit
bientôt
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à paris bah vu que je suis pas
dit si c'est vrai que quand je suis
arrivé c'était un peu oppressant et ben
jassem
non parce que votre master jai pas de ça
j'ai attrapé la cravate bleue et chemise
a excellé par les tropiques
moi j'en ai ras-le-bol quoi c'est bon
quoi tu dois tout c'est vrai [ __ ]
partout ses oreilles vous circulez vous
même en trottinette what she wrote à
trottinette que tu dis tu avais commence
par te suit la foutue je penses tu à
jouer de la mandoline je te le dis vous
êtes seul oui jumelles mais pollue sans
parler de plus en plus omniprésente a
surtout en période de chaleur on en
respire plus le problème c'est les
et ils en pensent quoi votre frère mon
frère mon frère il en pense que il voit
par impact man je la vois pas je vois
pas l'impact de la pollution il a raison
il me connaît on est comme ça on est on
a vécu ensemble
non pas que c'est une chose on amène une
autre puis après celle escalade de
l'horreur après tu te fais un oeuf au
plat
aujourd'hui tu peux plus le faire
tranquillement voilà l épicier à madame
diago je dis merci la classique et
continue que pour six comme ça faut pas
question de s'arrêter par les critiques
des gens qui ont plutôt vouloir avoir
beaucoup de voitures dans paris
c'est mieux à l'heure vers l'est je
demandais s'il aimait les trottinettes
électriques
arrête de regarder a été tranquille je
suis ta photo sport tu vas jouer du
biniou je peux te dire
hélas
[Musique]
je suis master 3g plus de 60 ans et donc
je pratique la colle à la course à pied
en compétition
vous courez tous les jours non pas tous
les tubes malheureusement parce que
j'habite à 1h30 de bon travail donc je
couvre trois à quatre fois par semaine
et votre soeur elle aussi fait du
running
non666 yearlings je vais me mettre la
shoah mais j'ai fait j'ai fait trois
bornes là je ne perds trois bornes je
suis sur les rotules et toi tu fais
combat déjà à moi je fais juste qu'on
marathon 42 km en 2 tio mais je ne veux
même pas en voiture
ouais j'suis un peu la leur comme des
belettes vous rentrez chez vous encore
en trottinette paristech tête aux pieds
qui se livrent un reggae
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]